christian saint-palais bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors à l'instauration d'un état
d'urgence sanitaire bouleverse on lisait
profondément la justice notamment le
droit des justiciables
concrètement qu'est ce qui change pour
eux dans ce contexte d'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais concrètement la plupart
des procès sont interrompus ce qui était
en cours à ce qu'ils étaient étalés sur
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
comme le procès du médiator est
incomplet et il devrait reprendre le 1er
juin tout ce qui était programmé pour
une après midi une journée ou deux jours
et pour l'essentiel dès lors que ce
n'est pas considéré comme urgent
suspendu reporter mais il reste bien sûr
au pénal des affaires et qui sont celles
aux gens qu en tout cas par les
procureurs de la république et qui
justifie soit des gardes à vue
c'est à dire démolition au sein des
commissariats soit des audiences qui
sont des audiences de comparution
immédiate
ou alors des audiences qui ont pour
objet de juger des faits qui sont
estimés grave est reproché à des
personnes qui sont en prison et qui sont
donc jugés soit extraite de la prison
jusqu'au tribunal soit par
visioconférence donc il ya peu
d'audience mais il reste des audiences
et des avocats pénalistes sont toujours
sur le terrain qu'en ce moment
ben quoi cette disparition
général 1 d'audience publique oral et
contradictoire inquiète votre profession
alors pourquoi d'hier était quand même
désordre dans une ordonnance a été pris
dans matière pénale qui est très
contesté par les pénalistes parce que
incontestablement elle porte atteinte
aux libertés fondamentales
il est tout à fait normal que dans une
circonstance particulière que nous
connaissons se sont dits qui est tout à
fait exceptionnel il est tout à fait
normal qu'on est un petit aménagement de
l'état de droit
la question qui se pose de craie de la
mesure vous avez dit tout à l'heure dans
votre présentation que on envisager que
la collégialité soit abandonnée et qu'on
est reproché liszt est vrai que
l'ordonnancé prévoit qu'on ne pourra y
avoir recours très régulièrement est
prévue la visioconférence c'est une
mesure exceptionnelle pour obliger au
pénal vous dit que effectivement il peut
être nécessaire d'y avoir recours actuel
dont tellement on veut craindre la
contamination par le transfert des uns
et des autres et la représentation des
lieux publics oui on peut avoir recours
à des mesures exceptionnelles en une
occasion d'exceptionnel mais de là ce
qui peut heurter c'est le cul nu toutes
les mesures dérogatoires qui font que
nous sommes dans un état de droit qui
est quand même très contraint et nous
avons eu en plus des dispositions
relatives à la détention provisoire
c'est à dire les gens qui ne sont pas
encore au succès qui sont en détention
provisoire de manière exceptionnelle
dans l' attente de leur procès et pour
lesquelles on a augmenté la durée de
cette détention provisoire jusqu'à six
mois pour certaines d'affaires et nous
avons découvert à la publication d'une
circulaire d'avant-hier que des notions
ce qui était déjà organisé pour statuer
sur la prolongation de cette détention
provisoire ces auditions se sont abîmés
par la circulaire alors c'est à dire que
nous avons régularisé des recours ou et
que le conseil d'état va être saisi dans
les tout prochains jours pour statuer
sur la légalité de cette ordonnance
alors on a bien compris cette question
de négation des droits de la défense
pour conclure qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous pour préserver
ce droit de la défense dans la situation
actuelle je dis d'abord que les avocats
sont toujours présents et qu'il faut
organiser des conditions sanitaires
permettant à tous les avocats de
descendre dans des conditions qui
protègent les justiciables et qui
protège le d'avocats d'aujourd'hui vous
n'avez dans les tribunaux aucun masque
aucun gant et fort peu de zèle qui est
distribué
nous avons besoin d'entretien
confidentiel pendant la garde à vue et
avant les audiences de comparution
immédiate ce que nous reprochons
actuellement à 50 chefs de juridiction
et de pannes est de ne pas être à
disposition des avocats des pièces
permettant la sécurité de l'entretien
vous savez que le tribunal de paris est
un tribunal une once qui vient d'être
construit c'est un vaisseau qui
aujourd'hui évident on ne peut pas
prétendre qu'il n'y a pas de salle
suffisantes pour organiser des
entretiens confidentiels et qui
permettent la sécurité du justiciable et
bien jusqu'à aujourd'hui
le bâtonnier a été obligé de suspendre
les conditions de piste il n'y a pas
d'avocats pour les investisseurs les
plus faibles parce que nous n'avons pas
des conditions de sécurité optimales
pour les étudiants ça c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'il faut absolument
dénoncé il est possible de défendre dans
des circonstances exceptionnelles et
c'est ce que nous demandons merci
beaucoup christian saint-palais d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat et président de
l'association des avocats pénalistes